aujourd'hui je m'adresse à tous les
rêveurs dans cette pièce et à tous ceux
qui nous on regarde présentement à la
maison à tous ceux qui ont encore des
plus ardents les yeux à tous ceux qui
ont encore cette grève intérieur vous
savez cette fête qui doit vous avez
depuis l'enfance celle qui vous pousse à
faire des choix éclairés
lucide ou complètement fou mais toujours
toujours en fonction de vos rêves fait
voir mais d'abord c'est quoi rêver il y
aller il ya les rêves qu'on fait quand
on dort vous avez remarqué la belle
jessica alba ou encore le beau brad pitt
je dois vous avouer que moi aussi des
fois je rêvais où est donc c'est ça ou
vous y attendez pas celle là où il
encore il ya aussi les rêves que l'on
fait qu'on ait réveillé ses rêves le on
les classe en trois catégories bien
distinctes
il ya d'abord les rêves abordables les
rêves d'une vie et les rêves
inaccessibles mais d'abord parlons des
rêves abordable par exemple ça ferait
d'aller sur le site d'air canada ou d'un
air transat ou de simplement bouquet un
billet d'avion puis d'aller à venise ou
encore de passer devant une animalerie
le voir le beau golden retriever devant
toi et te dire je l'achète
c'est mon rêve à moi ou encore
finalement de sculpter un corps de rêve
telles que arnold swarzenegger ou encore
à voir le rêve de bien prononcer son nom
tamis soir donnait guère on peut le
vivre ensemble où tu as fait un rêve
abordables ou encore finalement tôt le
rêve d'une vie
les rêves ont les quelques qui croient
réellement mais qui demande beaucoup de
dévouement et de travail et il faut que
tu y crois par exemple si je retourne à
la dernière diapositives ou à fonder une
famille c'est important pour toi de
fonder une famille c'est la rêve d'une
vie ou encore de créer son entreprise
crée ton invention ou est simplement les
fois que tu regardes tu es au vieux port
de montréal se regarde et vois ligne
c'était dit moi aussi un jour je faire
le tour du monde en voilier
c'est la raison des flammes en revue les
rêves inaccessibles
c'est le reste qui pensent tout en
vantant dormant la dernière chose
peut-être à la quelques types ans par
exemple voyager dans l'espace ou encore
sauver la planète
sauver la planète de la pollution ou
encore gagné un prix nobel et prix nobel
de la paix a gagné un oscar par exemple
ce sont tous des rêves inaccessibles et
que peut être certains d'entre nous les
plus chanceux - capable d'y arriver mais
savez-vous ce qu'ils ont en commun
ces trois types de règles c'est toi tu
es fais ta propre limite tu es tu as
propres limites et je vais te dire
puis je faire les banques prêtent banal
pour vous et vous allez tout de suite
comprendre qu'est ce que je veux dire
l'analogie que j'ai avec ça c'est comme
si c'est un cuisinier et de ton four
swords and mail à vingt cinq étoiles la
meilleure la zain de table ou finalement
qui décide de choisir de certaines la
dengue semblant satisfaisante juste
correct c'est toi qui choisis quel rêve
que tu veux accomplir qu'est ce que tu
vas finir par sortir du four mais je
vous entends déjà plus loin
karina comment qu'on fait pourra couper
notre rêve c'est quoi la recette c'est
que paris est magique c'est quoi la
recette magique
il ya deux ingrédients puis je vais vous
les communiquer vous allez me remercient
plus tard donc il faut que tu cries une
harmonie entre la sagesse et la folie ça
a l'air simple mais je te répète il faut
que ça rentre dans ta tête prend tant
que ça rentre dans ta tête il faut créer
une harmonie entre la sagesse et la
folie la folie c'est quoi c'est l'espèce
d'étincelles
que tu as tu estimes chaque matin avec
un projet en tête
qui t'a fait espérer de tout coeur que
tu vas finir par l'apport ou encore on
attelle qui qu'on appelle la sagesse
c'est celle qui qu'on associe souvent
déclage celle qu'on associe souvent avec
les cheveux blancs avec le temps mais au
final la confusion que charlie c'est
simplement des excuses que l'on se donne
pour justifier nos actions qu'elle soit
lucide éclairé ou complètement inerte
c'est finalement ces jeux des excuses
que l'on se donne donc c'est ça la
recette miracle c'est de créer une
harmonie entre la sagesse de la police
et croyez moi je voudrais les phrases
qu'on mette vite car n'en des
compléments fun de 26 ans sera jamais
une femme d'affaires accomplie
ton rêve de vivre une vie comme s'il n'y
avait pas de lendemain
c'est juste pour l'île sous existe pas
mais à toi je te réponds tu préfères est
une personne pleine de vie d'ambition et
de défi personnel que de l'imaginer un
seul jour dans ma vie avec aucune raison
d'être
la vie d'adulte à nous rattrape
rapidement d'accord on travaille tout le
temps pour soi tout le temps des
courriels sur notre île l'ère open
europe 1 auprès par l'europe
on paie nos factures on emmène aux
enfants la garderie sa part a dit jamais
finalement quand on est adulte se
produit quand on est adulte on oublie de
rêver on oublie de rêver on se glisse
dans la facilité on se glisse finalement
dans une vie simple parce que c'est
facile en semaine par exemple ce serait
créer une harmonie entre la sagesse et
la feuille
donc je vous ai parlé aussi de l'espèce
d'étincelles
l'étincelle
quand il était telle qu'on a qu'on garde
avec nous si ma faute c'est l'espèce de
bougie d'allumage qui te fait ouvrir les
yeux picotent se gardent au fond de ce
parc est ce que tu la perdras jamais et
bien moi ça leur sert partage un peu
plus difficile je lis perdu cette
étincelle en 2011
le jockey ma vie a complètement bousculé
j'avais 18 ans et oman ont figé passé
des semaines à l'hôpital et on may a
noté karine ta vie va changer la vie va
changer d'avis de 18 ans être plus
jamais comme la vie comme les autres
j'ai passé des mails à l'hôpital à ne
remettra en question comme c'est
pourquoi ça m'arrive à moi on m'a
annoncé que j'allais devoir avoir des
perfusions à chaque de moi que j'allais
me rendre à voir des personnes à chaque
du monde mais le plus dur dans tout ça
c'est l'été celle que j'avais dès le
départ laisse la vie que j'espérais
avoir je pouvais toujours l'avoir mais
avec beaucoup plus d'efforts c est par
le j'ai vu quand j'ai eu des critiques à
mon niveau
après les pronostics et les critiques
des médecins ils ont même abordé maman
que je vous racontais audi r4 nan t'as
filles c'est fini a pourrait plus jamais
travailler 40 heures semaine puis jamais
je vais devoir m'adapter
puis vous savez ce que ma mère m'avait
répondu non marc larre a répondu puis je
m'en suis encore aujourd'hui parce que
c'est une phrase à laquelle je me suis
accroché elle a dit ne connais pas ma
fille regarde la dialyse à va finir par
réussir mais vous savez ce que j'ai
compris une finale c'est que les
critiques
elles vont toujours être inévitable si
tu te donne le droit de rêver prenons
l'exemple de barack obama trop noir pour
être président une personne de couleur
ne veut pas être prise ou encore chantal
maccabi mon idole de jeunesse
une femme comment une femme peut
rayonner dans le monde du sport comment
elle peut être une analyse sportive
reconnue aujourd'hui dans les médias
sportifs ou encore prenons l'exemple de
martin st louis trop petit pour accéder
à la ligue nationale
pourtant le gagner une coupe stanley
puis est devenu deux fois meilleur
marqueur de la ligne mais réussir malgré
les obstacles les critiques se disent il
faut vraiment vraiment tel courage mais
ma mère m'a toujours dit le courage
c'est quoi c'est d'abord par mais
d'avancer quand même finalement et non
le moindre d'un des plongeurs un
astronaute un astronaute de saint
lambert saint lambert et le cnam a
réussi là voyager dans l'espace
finalement la règle était pas trop grand
pour lui ou trop inaccessible
donc ce que j'ai appris parce que
j'aimerais vous partager à la fin de
cette conférence c'est que pour être
heureux
j'ai lu et j'ai relu à travail social et
puis je veux partager cette connaissance
le les gens les plus heureux c'est ceux
qui se permettent de faire un bilan à
chaque année de leurs rêves et de
dresser une liste de toutes les aides
les objectifs et de toutes les règles
que tu va accomplir dans ta vie là
j'attends je vais vous poser une
question c'est quand la dernière fois
que tu t'adresses mu c'est quand la
dernière fois que tu as pris le temps
d'écrire terrain vtt objectif pour les
atteindre cette somme d'erreurs dans mon
dernier meeting avec mon patron aux
états dit
mes objectifs mais rêvent d'accomplir
dans la dans la société c'est pas ça
rêver faut qu'ils prennent le temps de
le faire des choix orienté pour les
atteindre mais souvent nombreux d'entre
nous on va te créer une espèce de
barrières psychologiques
on va avoir peur on va avoir des deals
des désillusions on va avoir pas de se
faire juger par les autres mais c'est
que sa vie que dès le moment que tu te
libères de tes propres limites
ils savent et c'est quoi le seul risque
le seul risque c'est d'inspirer les
autres
finalement et de laisser une legacy
derrière toi faut que tu partes
conscience à des deux meilleurs amis ce
que je t'ai parlé en début de conférence
l'harmonie et la sagesse aussi que tu
apprennes à s'entourer des personnes qui
te vois vraiment qu'ils croient en toi
aussi tu perds confiance prennent des
risques et d'enfants et quelques crétins
d'être heureux aujourd'hui quelques
traités d'aller voir des paysages à
couper le souffle ou encore de monter le
mont everest ou encore d'apprendre une
nouvelle langue que ce soit l'heureux
soul espagnol ou encore simplement de
d'admirer pschitt soleil des rires à
chaudes larmes et de la mairie tokyo
soleil qu'est ce qui te retient pour
être heureux c'est petter idéaliste et
être romantique mais c'est la seule
semaine pour être heureux saleh était
prouvé aujourd'hui que cette adresse un
bilan des rêves à chaque année crois moi
ça va être plus heureux que la majorité
des gens autour de toi donc crois en toi
même si tu crois toi même si les gens ne
croient pas en toi donne toi la chance
de vivre une vie heureuse donne toi la
chance de vivre une vie à la hauteur des
attentes et surtout de ton potentiel
c'est tout pour moi les rêveurs merci
[Applaudissements]